うぇーーくそー!
花粉、うぜーーーー！！！！（切実）
鼻水がすごい出ます。はじめしゃちょーです。
はい、というわけで今日の動画なんですけども
もうしわけないっす
ごめん！!
しょうもないんですけれども、誰もが一度はやってみたいと思ったことでしょう
コレ！知ってますか？
おおお～
これ、あれです！なんか、イヤリングっていうか。なんかピアスとか
イヤリングってこうさ
耳に穴をあけて、バッシュッッッッッッッッッってそこになんかこうやって
そこにこうやってなんか
ってやんなきゃいけないのを
すごいイタくて嫌じゃないですか
なんか痛いのとか嫌なんでピアスとか開けないんですけど
これを使えば誰でもなんかね、その
イヤリングが出来てます的な雰囲気を
漂わせれます。パカって開いてここに耳を挟んでパチンってする。
一回やってみます。耳があってここにこうこうやってね
パチンてするともうほら
もうイヤリングですよ！どうですかピアスっぽくなってませんか
え、ほんと百個あんのか、これ？。
イッチ！ニ！
１００！（余りを分ける。）
チョット多かった！これは取っておいて
これはまぁ取っといて
合計１００個の
ニセピアスがあります。とゆうわけで今日はあのう誰しもが
一度はヤりたいと思いませんか
やってみたいと思います！ワリィ！しょうもねぇ！しょうもないけどさあ
なんかピアスだらけの人とかいるじゃないでスカ！顔になんかすごい
鼻とかついてる。ああいうの見たらねぇ、すごいあのうあの
何とも思わないんですけど。
まぁ一度はヤってみたいなという興味本位ではある。というところでございます。
どんどんけていきましょう
イテ！結構がっつりだなぁ。もうどんどん付けていきますよ
やっばイカツイカツ！もうこの時点でいかつい・・・。
ウホ！ウホッホーウオッオッ！ヤンキーだぁ！（驚）
でも、こういう人いるんだよなぁ。実際。俺見たことあるもん！
原宿で。うわスッゲー。うわすっげー！オーオーオー。おーおーおー！
いるいるいるぜっんぜんいる。逆行きます。はいはいはい、
いってー！あ、こういうのあるね。ちょま、どうなってるかわっかんないけどなるべくやってみます。
まってまって耳が取れそう。
ア、チョイ！
あーいるいる。ちょっと思ったのと違うなぁ。あ、いるいるいる！
これほんとに百個付けれんのかなぁ？
唇がすごい！え、こんなに重い！？まって、やばい。
できました。
はいというわけで、無事百個つける事ができました。
（後輩君）フフッッッッ
（後輩君）フッッフッッ
オラーーーーーーー！！
ややや待って待って
時間の終わりだ
いてっいてっ！助けて！ねぇ！とるのめんどくさい！
イテテ。ヤバッ！ヤバイ。イッテ！ズズー
ウハハハハーーーハーハーハーハーマッテ！ハ～ウッヒーッヒーヒーッヒーたすけて！これ取れないんだよぉスーハースーハ
ねぇちょこれ取って！ズー。イテー